tenir bébé et ses petites sqp ce soir je
vais dîner les gastambide et j'ai annulé
le dîner pour être là ce soir parce que
c'était hamel
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand même le dérangeait pas
déranger les gens non mais je veux dire
en ml on ne m'a jamais l'heure à l'ordre
au daguestan beach et devait dire m
là c'est dingue parce que c'est possible
parce qu'il m'embrouille tout à l'heure
tu vois je viens d'avoir une tribune à
l'offrir au savon frère mon frérot je
suis à l'antenne mon frère parce que
j'ai toujours ma petite émission tout ça
c'est qu'on essaie du mois et oui
pourquoi ton truc de rappeler ouais là
bas de chez toi t'es vraiment un fidèle
toi moi je veux dire 60 m en a toujours
et ce soir tu devais faire quoi tu avais
quoi de prévu fils john allan alors sur
ma vie qu' aucun pacte ni tu fais pas ce
soir qu'on soit il ya parce que tu
devais pas manger avec de leurs mots
soir à
[Applaudissements]
nous dire il vient de nous dire ce soir
je suis là j'ai dû annuler le hajj il
est avec franck gastambide on est avec
vous tu ne comptait en juillet au
cabinet questions rapides
oui on peut savoir du coup comment
franck gastambide une star est aussi
beau et libre ce soir si j'ai pas comme
par hasard annulé sa soirée alors
comment l'affecté libre ce soir il a
travaillé mais voilà bon bah écoute ça
fait bizarre ducasse et donc c'est
impossible d ensemble un jour
vraiment c'est pas du tout mais je
t'appelle tout à l'heure féraud
[Applaudissements]